said you were going to New Jersey
because there's better internet yeah I
mean is that true yeah the for nicer
version like Northern Virginia I'm in
Florida so my connection is terrible I'm
at extreme disadvantage so are you
actually moving they're moving there you
just go in there for a few days
well my teammate cloaks has a house in
Jersey so yeah I spent about five
thousand dollars on audio equipment and
gaming equipment and I hit up digital
storm tell him to send me a few
computers so I'm just kind of set up
there whenever I want to play with a low
ping advantage I just can't go to Jersey
whenever I want
so Wow so like when there's tournament
big tournaments whatever you know they
really yeah yeah yeah and the servers
are there like the fortnight the servers
are like Ohio and they're in like
Virginia okay yeah so the closer you are
the faster the connection the better you
can build faster you can go the faster
you can get it the more walls you can
take sweet dude well what do you think
of my setup do you think I'm doing it
right you got any suggestions for me